Bei einigen Menschen sollen diese Aufnahmen
eine Gänsehaut erzeugen, die vom Kopf startet
und dann angenehm den Rücken entlang läuft.
Genannt wird das Phänomen "Autonomous Sensory
Meridian Response" und gilt als beruhigendes
Gefühl, das unter anderem durch visuelle
und akustische Sinnesreizung ausgelöst wird.
Die Autorin der Filmaufnahmen heißt Laura
Driskill.
Und sie hat sich auf diese Art von Nahaufnahmen
spezialisiert.
Dabei schneidet die US-Amerikanerin mit einer
zuvor stark erhitzen Messerklinge durch die
mit Glitter angereicherten Wackelpuddinge.
Auf Instagram wurden bereits mehrere Videos
hochgeladen.
Einige davon wurden über 2,6 Millionen Mal
angeschaut